With that, I'm going to introduce, uh, Dr. Savage.
Dr. Sam Savage is an adjunct profen- professor in
Civil and Environmental Engineering at Stanford University
and Executive Director of Probability Management and
Non-profit devoted to making uncertainty actionable.
Dr. Savage is also the author of the Flaw of Averages,
why we underestimate risks in the face of uncertainty
and as the inventor of the Stochastic information packet,
SIP, a standardized data array for con- conveying uncertainty.
And so he's very qualified to talk to us today,
er, about how to manage risk in big projects.
And he will also be teaching with us in the winter.
You saw some of those slides at the beginning,
at CEE242R, a course on Project Risk Analysis.
This is a graduate seminar but we are accepting people from outside Stanford.
So if you are an, uh, online learner who might
be interested in joining that class, you can enroll.
Just go to SCPD, uh, SCPD's website.
Okay. With that, I'm going to turn over the presentation to Sam and you'll take it away.
Alright, er, thanks Pax.
I know that we have people who are probably very broad, er, background in,
in- in their education and, er,
I like to start by leveling
the playing field by- by starting out with something that everybody understands.
These are the differential equations of motion of a bicycle.
The point of this slide is to show that you do not learn to ride
a bicycle through the seat of your intellect but through the seat of your pants.
And I've a name for this,
I call it Limbic Analytics.
The limbic system is that part of the brain that connects
the reptilian brain to the rest of the stuff between your ears and,
computers have allowed us to learn formally difficult stuff without limbic systems,
er, It's really very exciting.
So I refer to limbic analytics,
uh, as Connecting the Seat of the Intellect to Seat of the Pants.
In my book on the flaw of averages,
er, there's a cartoon of this by the
Cartoonist is Jeff Danziger so here's
someone connecting the seat to their intellect to and seat of their pants.
And, er, so the- the philosophy of the course and by the way,
new technology has really enabled, er,
this approach, er, i- in analytics and, er,
I want to start out now with the notion of the Flaw of Averages.
So the flaw of averages, explains, er,
basically why everything [inaudible]
why so many projects are behind schedule,
beyond budget, and below the projection.
And we're just going to start out with- with the,
er, behind schedule part.
So suppose the project involves creating a new website and
it consists of 10 pages without
the shopping cart page and the legal page and the credit card page whatever.
Naturally, we're uncertain about how long each page will take to complete but
they- they are being created in parallel,
uh, by 10 separate teams.
So this is the best of all possible projects.
Team 1 does Page 1,
Team 2 does Page 2.
When we get all 10 pages done,
we can launch, uh, the website.
But of course we're uncertain about how long each team will take.
So on average, they take six weeks but who,
you know, that could happen or that could happen or that could
happen but on average there six weeks.
So here's- here is where the flaw of averages comes in.
The boss comes in and says, ''Hey,
when's the website can be up,'' and you say,
''I don't know boss because I don't know how page- long page one will take
a Page 2 or Page 3 and then the boss says, ''Correct me if I'm wrong.
Give me a number.''
Now give me a number is actually the fork in the road
to hell because after you've done that,
you really can't do anymore analysis if you give them a number but you say to the boss,
''I can't give you a number but I can give you an average.''
Because on average, each of these is six weeks.
So on average, this project will be done in six weeks,
and the boss says well if I can give you an average
okay and you've told me six weeks, so that's what we're thinking about.
Now, um, I'd like to ask you a question here,
you don't have to answer it on the poll because we've already done this poll.
Just think for a second,
what is the chance that this project will actually be done in six weeks?
A hundred percent, 50 percent, 1 in 4,
1 in 10,1 in 100,1 in 1,000,1 in 10,000 let it sink for just a bit on that.
Last year we did a poll on this,
so I know the answers.
I know what you think the answers are. Okay, here it goes.
Most people think, uh,
50-50 chance would be done in six weeks.
The correct answer is 1 in 1,000.
And it's not enough to just understand that
but you've got to be able to explain it to your boss or say a 10 year-old.
Okay, so let me explain why it's 1 in 1,000.
Imagine that each of these ten pages,
the duration of each of the ten pages [NOISE]- is
either over six weeks or under six weeks determined by a coin toss.
Well the only way you can go live in six weeks is if all 10 of these
coming in at six weeks or under and
that's like flipping 10 heads in a row which is actually 1,000 and,
er, er, one chance in 1,124.
So that's why, er,
the answer here is about 1 in 1,000.
Now, er, I think it's important
to point out that there been some technological breakthroughs ,uh,
that have allowed, uh,
enabled a new discipline that I call Probability Management.
And Probability Management makes
uncertainty actionable by storing it as auditable data.
As an example-
Let's- let's do dice here.
I'm gonna start out with dice then we're gonna go
back to that scheduling example which is
kinda like the- like the granddaddy of all the big,
ah, flaw of averages problems.
Um, so here I've got
data representing 10,000 die rolls for each of three dice.
I- if you've heard a Monte Carlo simulation,
then these data arrays are just the output of a Monte Carlo simulation.
But here's the coolest thing,
there's been break through, ah, in Excel,
where there- there's a function called
the Data Table which has recently become much more powerful.
And, ah, so by looking at these dice,
by the way, see there's trial one is a four, a six,
and a five; trial two is a three, a two, and a six.
Um, trial like 8,700, so that one.
No, that's not it. Let me try 7,005.
Well, for this one,
I don't know, sorry.
[LAUGHTER] One of them in there is three ones,
and I forget which one but it's auditable data is the point.
Um, 9,765, is that it?
There we go. See, I haven't memorized all 10,000 trials. I knew it was one of those.
Okay. But that's amazing.
So that means that- that this-
this whole simulation approach is auditable but watch this.
I can say, what happens if I roll that first die 10,000 times?
Get your stopwatch.
On your mark, get set, go.
Okay. That was 10,000 die rolls.
Wha- what happens if I add two dice together?
So I'll add the first die to the second die and now,
what I'm doing is I'm doing arithmetic with uncertainty.
Now, when I add two dice, the smallest number you can get is a two.
The biggest number you can get is a 12.
You get those with equal likelihood.
See this histogram we are looking at says, "oh yeah,
all the dice come up, all the sides come up equally likely."
But if I add two of them together, whoa,
and that was 10,000 Monte Carlo trials in native Excel.
Well, then I see there are more sevens than anything
else because there are more ways to get a seven.
Now, in the discipline of probability management,
where we store uncertainties as arrays of data,
these things have names, these arrays.
I decided to call them,
uh, you know what I already knew that, you know,
the audience out there has got bit and byte,
you know, permanently tattooed into your brain somewhere.
So, uh, I knew I needed SIP and SLURP just to fit into the receptors you already had.
Ah, SIP stands for stochastic information packet.
That's one of these columns.
And SLURP is- is tortured but it's stochastic library unit with relationships preserved.
W- we may or may not get to that, ah,
during this lecture but it's very important when you have
multiple uncertainties to preserve any inter-relationship between them.
So now let's go back to the scheduling problem.
First thing to say is gee,
how do you define the flaw of averages?
While the flaw of averages states that plans based on
average assumptions are wrong on average.
So, uh, for example, oh yeah,
most people think this will be done in six weeks in 50- 50-50 chance.
Right, there's one chance with 1,000,
that's not close enough even for government work.
Um, so- so here's one example of the flaw of averages.
Uh, consider a statistician who drowned in the river that's on average three feet deep.
A- again this is another, uh,
cartoon by Jeff Danziger who's illustrated the book.
Um, he- here's a more sobering example.
Consider a drunk wandering back and forth in a busy highway.
Ah, his average position is the center line.
Well, that means that at his average position, the drunk is alive.
Yeah, but on average,
he's dead not close enough even for government work.
Now, this- this was discovered.
This is a mathematical principle known as Jensen's inequality.
And, um, just one of the other points here.
Um, i- in the Flaw of Averages book, um,
one of the big problems here i- in statistics,
ah, is that most people had statistics course.
I've got what I call post-traumatic statistics disorder or PTSD.
And so it's important not to use too much statistical jargon.
So in the back of the book,
I have a glossary.
Well, first of all, I have a term for these words that bring on, ah, PTSD.
I call them red words.
So let me just show you the red word.
The green word, green means it's okay.
You can say it. The flaw of averages.
You can say the flaw of averages.
The red word equivalent that you heard in your math course or
statistics course is Jensen's inequality.
And, uh, tha- that the final definition of
a red word is something that could not be uttered in a singles bar for example.
But anyway there's- there's a glossary in the back of the book of these red words
and green words and that we don't really need to zoom in there but you know,
when you get there, they're written in Dracula font but the- this is the publishers idea.
I love it. So I go back now to the drunk in the road.
Mathematicians have known about this for over a century as Jensen's inequality.
I call it the flaw of averages.
This was a public relations issue here.
And as a public relations issue, ah,
I developed an audio logo for the flaw of averages.
So here you- you recognize this audio logo,
you should be able to hear this.
[MUSIC] That's, ah, of course,
you know, a- a big chip maker.
You should recognize their audio logo.
Here's the flaw of averages audio logo.
[MUSIC] So let's go back now to this project model.
And- and I'm gonna show you now how we actually ca- can make
actionable decisions based on uncertainty.
We- to start out with,
we have a SIP library.
That- that is to say this was not your first rodeo.
You've been building web pages for a while.
You know how long it takes to build web page.
Yeah, it's uncertain.
We can model that uncertainty with a SIP library.
Ah, so here we have 1,000 possible, uh, scenarios.
And so when I'm scrolling through,
I'm looking through each of the 1,000 possibilities.
Oh, you wanted 10,000,
I give you 10,000. You want a million?
We could do a million. That- that would be Excel's limit
but you want to do it in Python or R or something else.
You could do 100 million if you needed to, 1,000 probably enough.
So this is a business problem however.
Unfortunately, uh, someone has promised this job in
seven weeks and if you miss seven weeks then,
uh, there's $100,000 per week late penalty.
Lucky, they didn't promise six weeks.
So let's take a look at this.
If I plug in the averages and I'm done in six weeks with no penalty.
No, that can't happen.
Like- like this scenario one,
68,000 in penalty, 7.7 in scenario two.
I don't want the output giving the average input.
I want the average of this over all thousand trials.
That's what the flaw of average is, distinguishes between them.
And this again is just a native Excel file.
You could- you can download this off the ProbabilityManagement.org
website and share it with 1.2 billion of your closest friends.
It's just native Excel.
Um, I didn't show you this before but we're using the data table out here
to run 1,000 trials,
you know, with every keystroke basically.
And so now let's take a look at what the average results are.
Average of all 1,000 trials.
So the outcome of the average inputs is six weeks and
no penalty but on average it's 7.8 weeks and $86,833.
[MUSIC]
The difference between these two is the flaw of averages.
Now, how would we use this to make better decisions?
Well, the first thing is you,
you go crawling back to the counter-party on your hands and knees.
They, "Oh please, please, please,
would you lower our penalty for 50,000?"
But notice you're getting nailed here.
On average, it's like almost 87,000.
So let's lower the penalty to 50,000, right?
And they say," Oh, we'd be happy to do that but then we're
gonna demand that you finished in six weeks." "Oh, no.
Now our penalty is 92,000 bucks. Oh my God".
So you say, "Wait a second.
How about if we- would give us eight weeks to finish?"
They say, "Sure, we're happy to do that.
If you finish- if, if,
if you are willing to accept a $150,000 penalty," and you say, "Sold."
That's 23,000, um, on average.
Okay, so really, uh,
what's important here is
that the discipline of probability management is going to let us determine;
number one, the true average of things
happening and number two is the chance of things happening.
So let me show you a couple of other examples of the flaw of averages,
and just so you understand, uh,
that this is not an isolated phenomenon but is actually, uh, ubiquitous.
So I don't know if anyone has ever heard of the potential of
say sea level rise or just flooding in general.
It is an example where we have a little municipality,
they have a creek that floods There are dikes along side of the creek.
The average flood crest by the way is 2.4 meters and,
and the height of the dikes is 2.5 meters.
So given the average flood,
there's no damage at all.
Here's a little table of damage down here, right?
So at 1.82 meters,
the nursery school flood, that's a million bucks.
Then the firehouse at 5 million,
then the railroad station at 10 million,
the airport at 20 million funded the hospital up here at five meters.
So, uh, let's remember it's easy to get a SIP library.
The SIP is this array of potential floods and,
uh, this is why we have a national weather service to provide these things.
Because- let's remember a bunch of stuff that happened,
like they're actually a 1,000 floods in here that could happen.
Oh, yeah it could, you know, to go way down.
Oh, or that could happen or that could happen or that could happen, oops.
So what's happening is, on that trial,
we had 30 million in damage.
Uh, but of course,
given the average flood, there's no damage.
But what if you averaged over all possible floods?
Then the damage will be $5.5 million [MUSIC].
This is a- an absolutely ubiquitous problem.
Now, the, the course is gonna use my book,
and that I do not want to induce PTSD in people.
So it really turns out there are these fives,
I call them minders, okay?
A minder leads to the mind,
what a handle is for the hand.
A handle let's you grasp something like,
you know, like a hammer.
A minder, once you grasp one of these, these slippery concepts.
So the mind or for the flaw of averages,
is the drunk in the road or the statistician in the river.
But basically, one section of the book
is devoted to the minders and it's not even a big section.
But they're all, all five minders,
I only knows of five concepts are all based on one page in the book.
Um, uh, for those of you who have the book by the way,
it's on Page 47.
There are five things you really have to understand to improve your risk intelligence.
Risk intelligence is important concept.
That's what Limbic Analytics does is improve your risk intelligence.
You don't have to go off and look at things like
the differential equation of the motion of a bicycle,
you can just know that stuff is wrong.
So, so let me give you some other- one other really interesting example of,
of where this whole probability management approach's being applied.
It, it just- it,
it just means that we are representing uncertainties as arrays of data.
Doesn't  just work in Excel, works anywhere.
There's this open standard called the SIP math
standard that can be applied in MATLAB in Python, in Excel.
One of the interesting places where- we're beginning to apply it now,
is military readiness actually.
So this is a conceptual model of an air wing on an aircraft carrier.
If somebody strikes fighters and growlers,
and these things and,
you know, these planes are not flying all the time.
You know they might be up about 80 percent of the time,
but you know they're fixing the flat tires,
their emptying the ashtrays or whatever the heck to do to keep the planes fine and
so you might have a eight mission requirement.
You say, "Listen, if we have to fly this mission today,
I need 30 strike fighters, three growlers,
three of these radar planes,
one of these and 12 helicopters."
What's my chance of being ready?
So let's go back to give me a number.
So give me a number- give me numbers the fork in the road to hell.
But the course is gonna teach you how to deal with that with the boss.
I'm just going to give you the bottom line.
When the boss says,
"Give me a number" you say,
"What do you want it to be?"
I'll tell you the chances are very important.
So if the boss wants this many aircraft of these types you say,
"Well, your chances 61 percent of carrying that notion off today.
Uh, if we just have to do it at random then we have to fly this thing 61 percent chance.
"So, uh,boss, "What you- what if I,
what if I back off the strike fighters?"
Oh, by the way, if we look down at the bottom of this sheet,
we're also learning that chance that
any particular type of aircraft was holding is up and receive the strike fighters.
In the event, we can't fly the mission,
there's a 43 percent chance that was a strike fighters,
35 percent chance it was the helicopters.
What if I back off to say, you know,
25 of these and I back off the helicopters to 10.
Wow, by doing that,
we've increased our chance of being able to fly
the mission to 82 percent from 61 percent.
Now, which mission to attempt to fly is above my pay grade.
But the person who makes that decision should be
informed with chances, not with averages.
All right. So let me now show you
a bit how we solve these problems from scratch.
And, er, oh, I'll tell you what,
le- le- because this is- this course is actually in project management.
Here's something I- I just have to show,
this is a template that just came straight out of Excel.
If you go to Excel and you open templates,
you open new file and put it in a little search,
and you- you put in like project planning or something,
this template pops up,
and we simply modified this to take in SIPmath.
So SIPmath being- means open standard for using the data table,
um, to do simulations.
So I'm gonna check this little box, click, whoa,
suddenly this thing is in simulation mode,
and you can do that or that, or that, or that.
By the way, one of the things we- we- we do in the class,
is I have students go down and- go ahead and
download these various project planning templates,
and then they can add their own probabilistic stuff into it.
Um, so- so this is taking this ready-made template,
and, you know, there's a little work to do it,
but not that much work that'll cut up to the data table.
Er, so that's- that's one of my favorite models.
Um, all right.
So- so let's now talk about,
sort of, applying this and- and the stuff
we're gonna learn in the course for- for building models.
Um, oh, and- and- I- before I do that,
I realized, um, I could do it after.
Th- this is all based on something in Excel called the Data Table function,
which you find here,
Data What-If Analysis data table.
Now the fact is, there are some free tools out of the nonprofit website,
where you can- where you can,
er, I'm going to demonstrate the tools in a second.
And they help you build the data table,
so you don't really need to do this, er, from scratch.
Okay, let's look at this model.
I told you that the flaw of averages explains why,
er, so many projects are behind schedule,
beyond budget and below projection.
This is the below projection project, er, and basically,
[NOISE] this would be something like a,
uh, a capital investment project.
We have to build a factory or something to produce
things or- or I'm gonna make a really simple version,
where we just have to order stuff for the Christmas season, but, um,
the point is, we have an uncertain demand for a product,
so here the cost per unit,
you gotta order six months in advance,
cost per unit is 30 bucks,
selling price 40 bucks.
We know that with certainty,
we're uncertain about the demand and again,
we have to order six months in advance.
But everybody agrees the average demand is 100,000 units,
so we order 100,000 units.
Now, the boss comes in and says,
what's profit going to be?
And you say, I don't know boss,
because I don't know what demand is going to be,
and then the boss says, give me a number,
and you say, would you settle for an average profit?
The boss says, if at all you can give me,
so well, that's easy enough.
We plug in 1,000 for our demand and revenue is 40 times 100,000,
we get 4- 4 million,
and the cost of goods was 30 times 100,000 that's 3 million,
so the profit is one million.
Yeah, that's the profit of the average,
but is that the average profit.
Um, so it doesn't take long to find a bulk.
What would happen if the demand was 90,000?
Well, if the demand is 90,000,
you only make $ 600,000.
Sure, but what if the demand was 110,000?
So what I'm doing here,
is I am experimenting with the model.
What if demand is a little higher? What if it's a little low?
So if the demand is a little low,
we went down to 600,000.
What if it's a higher? Oh oh,
we're still at a million dollars.
We're capped at a million dollars.
You can't make more than a million dollars 'cause you only ordered
100,000 of these widgets, whatever they are.
So let's go back to- to 100,000.
We see that the profit of 100,000 of the demand,
if the demand is 100,000, the profit is a million,
but if profit goes down, we make less money.
Profit goes up, we don't make more money.
How could something less than a million and something equal to a million,
average out to a million? It can't.
[MUSIC] The average isn't a million,
that's the best possible case.
Now, I am going to invoke the SIPmath module tools,
and again, the website is probabilitymanagement.org,
is a nonprofit, where you can grab these.
Um, and here's what I'm gonna do,
in this case, there is a SIP library waiting for me to plug in to this cell.
I don't know have- how to do Monte Carlo simulation to do this, right?
Let- let- let me give you an analogy here.
I presume that many of you have heard of Monte Carlo simulation, because I've- again,
it's not my first rodeo,
I- I know when people who show up these things, they've heard of Monte Carlo.
A technique developed during the Manhattan project where they developed the atomic bomb.
And to use Monte Carlo simulation,
you have to know a lot about statistics,
so you have to know how to generate
all these random numbers that go into your- into your model.
Um, and that's why people can't all use Monte Carlo, well that's one reason.
The other reason was you had to buy expensive Monte Carlo simulation software.
Okay, now you don't,
now Monte Carlo will run in native Excel,
so we got that problem out of the way.
But we still have the problem of, well,
I'm not an expert, how would I know how to generate the random numbers?
Well, let me ask you something,
do you use the light bulbs by any chance?
I bet you do. Do you know how to generate the electricity that goes into the light bulbs?
I bet you don't,
unless a few of you are working in a power company right now.
So how did we work that out?
Well, we had the electrical engineers generate the power in power plants
and then distribute it over power lines to the people who needed it,
and to do that, we had to invent a 60-cycle AC current standard.
Actually, the people invented it were called Westinghouse and Tesla.
Um, and, er, so now that we have that standard,
we can distribute- we can
distribute electricity from the people who generate to the people who need it.
We can now distribute probability distributions,
from the people who know how to generate them to the people who need them.
I call this distribution distribution.
So, um, what I'm gonna do is,
now use this SIPmath tools,
and it now wants- I could
generate electricity if I knew what outside a statistician, but I suppose I'm not,
I'm just, er, somebody who wants to predict the profit here,
and I'm gonna go to an external workbook.
And so I'm gonna browse for a workbook called Demand.
This workbook has in it,
a SIP of demand.
Here's that workbook, it just opened it for me.
And where's the SIP?
Oh, its right there with the plus sign,
all 1,000 trials of demand.
Good. Okay. Um, and it's got some metadata in here,
[NOISE] and its in this open standard format,
the SIPmath format, which also could be done in
XML or comma separated values or whatever.
So now I'm back at my model.
The next thing I do, is I put my cursor in that cell,
and I go to library input at,
oh, there's demand, so it now knows I have demand, I click okay.
I'm gonna overwrite the number.
Oh, wow, now I have a little picture of a distribution in that cell, how about that?
All it's done is put in an index statement to that other file now,
and so I could look at say, trial one,
trial two, trial three,
I think trial nine is coming up.
Oh yeah, trial nine is pretty nasty, isn't it?
Um, demand was 66,862,
yeah, you lost 325,000 on that trial.
Um, let me go back and set it to the average.
So given the average inputs,
we're making a million bucks,
you might want to know what the real average is, by the way.
So I put the cursor in that cell,
I click on Define Outputs.
I give it the name profit.
Oh, and let me just show you something here.
Before I do that, when I [NOISE] initialized the model,
it created a separate sheet where the data table is gonna be established.
Remember, at every stage,
I have a model that can be shared with 1.2 billion people.
The tools are like saw and hammer, working on wood.
If you build a dog house out of wood,
you don't need a saw and hammer,
the dog doesn't need a saw and hammer.
He used a doghouse, no.
You know, so Excel is the wood out of which we're building stuff.
And I just showed you this data table sheets.
There's nothing on it yet.
But as soon and I say, define outputs,
and I'm gonna give it a name profit,
I click okay, and a thousand trials later, oh,
my goodness, there are- there's a SIP of a thousand profits.
Oh yeah, well duh, the biggest number you can get is a million,
because you only ordered 100,000, um, 100,000 widgets.
Okay. Now, first question you might ask is,
what is the average profit?
With this- this data table over here,
it's actually named this range.
If I looked at range of outputs,
the range is called profits.
There's a range name, if you want range names on an Excel.
So I can simply go to the model.
And I could say, okay,
what's the average profit?
And I could type in equals average of profit.
And it says, "Oh, 600,000 roughly."
The profit of the average with a million,
the average profit is 600,000.
Not close enough even for folk music.
Now, the real question is,
what are the chances.
So how do you know you're doing probability management?
You're able to answer questions of the form,
"What are the chances of something?"
For example, a boss might say, "Well,
what's the chance of making 800,000?"
And, um, how do we do that?
Well, I- let's see, 800,000.
I want the chance that I'm greater than that.
I go over here.
I click on the chance of whatever button.
Here's my output. The chance that the thing is greater
than 800,000 is 58 percent.
Now, of course, I'm an expert.
So I knew that, I- I could do that in my head.
But, you know, you probably would have needed to do a-
a simulation to find out the chance that its greater- by the way,
what's the chance that its greater than 900,000?
Fifty-four percent. Now, I want to get to more of the stuff with the tools.
I had a nice question sent in to me that I want get to.
But, um, let's just do one of the kind of decision-making exercise here.
I hope you didn't tell the boss to expect a million dollars which you
would have done if you'd plugged in the average demand and then read off the closet.
But you probably didn't, too bad.
Nobody asked for this.
Why is it 100,000?
And why is it only a million?
Why we capped at a million?
Right? So- so in other words when- if I go up to like
a higher- let's go to a- let's go to a case where I have- oh, no, this is good enough.
[LAUGHTER] My- my actual demand is 141,000 but I only have
sales of 100,000 because all I can sell is what I ordered.
So if the actual is greater than the ordered,
I only get to sell the ordered, otherwise,
the actual- listen to me, "if" statement in Excel,
it means if. It's not that complicated.
So I didn't get to sell those extra ones.
So maybe I should have ordered more.
Like what if I ordered 120,000? Would that be better?
Let's try. Uh-oh, if you ordered 120,000,
your average profit is below 300,000, that's a disaster.
What if I ordered less?
Let's say order 80,000.
Oh, my profit is more.
It went up to 60- almost 680,000.
And by the way, this is where Limbic Analytics comes in.
Here, control Z, control Y,
control Z, back to ordering 100,000,
control Y ordering 80,000.
When you think Limbic Analytics,
you- you should think this scene in Jurassic Park,
where Jeff Goldblum is waving the flashlight in front of the Tyrannosaurus,
to keep it from eating the Jeep with kids in it.
Motion, you've gotta do things interactively to get the boss' attention.
Okay. Let's see if- if in the time remaining I can- I
can quickly answer what I thought was a very good question
here from someone on how to model cash flow,
and when you might run out of money.
So a very common thing in a project is
[NOISE] that [NOISE] you,
um- you have to start off by funding a project.
We'd say a million bucks.
And then eventually, they'll start bringing in cash.
But you don't get it right away.
So let's say that our cash out in this project,
our cash out is- by the way,
we have a million in funding.
So that's our cap. But we- we have to put in
like 250,000 in the first month and 250,000 in the second month.
Then we work our way down, 100,000, 100,000.
By the way, keeps 100- keeps 100,000,
that was just to keep the thing operating.
But then the cash starts coming in.
No cash first month, no cash second month.
But, you know, then you get,
uh, that's gonna be 50,000, then, 100,000, 100,000.
And then it starts in month eight,
it starts ramping up to 200,000.
And if you look at that,
here's your cash position over time.
Now this model point exists,
I should point something out.
What would happen if we required like,
uh, like 600,000 here?
Well, then you can see we get down very close to zero,
but we don't get to zero.
What if I needed 700,000 or 800,000?
Oh, when once you get to zero,
you stay at zero.
When you run out of money, you're dead, okay?
So there is the model, uh,
basically, out of the box violating the flaw of averages.
So now, let me show you how you would basically use the tools to- to model this.
And what I'm gonna use here,
we- we'll be learning how to use the tools in the course.
So I'm not expecting you- by the way,
there- there are- there are online tutorials, I think.
So I hope that- that you'll- you'll downloaded the free tools.
But it does take a little training
to do this stuff because now I'm not just using SIP libraries,
I'm actually learning electrical engineering, you know,
how to- how to model the uncertainty.
And one very simple way to model an-
an uncertain situations is with something called the triangular distribution.
And, uh, the triangular distribution is- is pretty brain-dead, let me say.
But, um- but I'm gonna use it to get us started.
So- so my first step here is I have estimates for each of these months.
This is for my cash-in.
I have a minimum and most likely and a max.
And I'm gonna turn those into uncertainties in the model.
So now, I'm gonna initialize the model.
I'm gonna say- I'm in generate mode.
I know what I'm doing. I'm gonna generate my own electricity. I click okay.
And then I'm gonna go to the cash-in section.
And I'm going to go to generate input and I gonna say,
this is gonna be a triangular distribution.
And I have the minimum,
and I have the most likely,
and I have the maximum.
Now it also needs me to put in one auxiliary set of data here to put in some-
some additional random numbers that- that drives the triangular distribution up.
But now- now, the cash-in column has got uncertainties in it- in it.
And I can scroll through them, here.
Trial one, trial two,
trial three, trial four, trial five,
trial six, uh-oh, it went bankrupt in trial- in month five, right?
And, uh- so let me put that one away.
I got- because I got one in the other already to come out here naturally, right?
I mean, uh, let me show you what- what you get to eventually, um-
So here we have a model in which it's pure Excel,
so I don't have to use the tools to scroll through the trials.
I would point that out. Uh, there's this number on
the PM table sheet which is called PM Index and,
um, I can control it from here.
There's trial 1, trial 2, trial 3,
trial 4, trial 5,
oh, oh, went bankrupt in month 4.
I have here- I have here, um, a cell.
This column of cells tracks the month in which I went bust.
And I don't go bust at all,
it puts a 100 in there and up here,
I have the minimum of those.
So oh, yeah.
I went bust in month 4.
If I go back to trial 1,
100 doesn't- doesn't mean I went bust in- in trial;
100 means that I didn't go bust at all.
And so looking for the average,
if when you went bust isn't even a sensible thing,
then you might never go bust, right?
The company might last forever.
You can't average like infinity and when you are about to- who I can ask the chance.
What the chance that I go bust in- in four months? Fourteen percent.
How about five months, six months?
How about 12 months, 13 months.
Well, 13 months is the highest,
I mean, this means you didn't go bust.
But that means there's a 43 percent chance you will
go bust within the first year which is important.
And then you could ask them questions like,
well, ooh, what if we went for more funding?
How about 1.2 million?
That didn't help that much.
Okay. How about two million?
Oh, oh, no wait a minute, uh,
hold on- hold on- hold on- hold on- hold on,
[NOISE] and do I look at the wrong cell?
Forty-three percent chance of going bust with a million.
Okay. 1.1 million that drops to six percent.
Oh, that might be something you'd like to know your funding this project, right?
1.2 percent, zero chance.
So I messed that up again.
But what you can see now with undo and redo,
look at this chance, we'll do a little limbic analytics,
chance of going bust with a million dollars with the funding, 43 percent, uh,
and then let's see, control  Y,
I let 1.1 million,
we're down to six percent, 1.2 million, we're at zero.
Okay. So there's an example of the kind of stuff that most people aren't even doing.
They're not talking about chances.
They're plugging in averages,
they're getting horrible answers,
and that's where they stopped.
So and this is what I would like to stop and take a few questions. [OVERLAPPING]
Thank you so much. Thank you so much, Sam.
Uh, so we just have- we have only a couple of minutes.
So I think there's one kind of- trying
to sort of organize all the questions in one central question.
So I- I love this idea of limbic a- analytics, um,
and we know even that from studies that most statisticians don't think
accurately about statistics outside of- when they're doing the actual statistical work.
So a- a couple of questions have come in about how do you deal, uh,
how have you seen changes in companies beyond the kind of
programs that you're doing to deal with this problem?
So someone mentioned Agile Project Development where you're dealing with instead of,
uh, uh, uh, giving a single number, you're giving a range.
What- what kinds of, uh, developments,
cultural developments have you seen in the companies to move towards a better,
um, understanding of probability and risk?
Yes. So the Agile development is- is just beautiful.
It is really in the bulls-eye of solving these problems.
If you can't, you're probably- probably with uncertainty.
Said just make your decisions more often as things change, right?
Um, you actually can prove using the flaw of averages that Agile development gives you
greater optionality which is one of
the things that the flaw of averages addresses so that
Agile development is definitely helping to solve these problems with uncertainty.
Um, I think interestingly though,
when it comes to maturely dealing with uncertainty,
you'll find some industries like finance.
So in finance, people look at risk return curves and they
have since the 1960s with regularity.
In option theory, people are looking at an uncertainty explicitly.
Um, but frankly there's a huge amount of
low-hanging fruit today to go out and adopt these methods today.
And for example, when you look at how
people do risk regulation- I think this is worth sharing.
I think this is a very, very important, um,
it- when people regulate risk,
here's an important definition of risk.
Um, likelihood of failure times consequences of failure.
So the likelihood of failure suppose that- so the failure is, you know,
there's an accident somebody gets- and- and if it
happens there's one chance someone gets killed, right?
Okay. But the- the likelihood- so LOF produces 10 percent- 10 percent chance
and the consequence
is one fatality, right?
And so this definition of risk says the risk here is
that times that or 0.1 fatalities.
And by the way this is used in regulation.
All right. Well, let me ask you this.
What if there was, uh,
a 0.01 percent, uh,
that's a one percent chance, oh, okay.
Let's see, of 100- of- of 10 fatalities. Well, wait a minute.
That's still 0.1.
Wha- what if there was,
uh, 0.01 percent chance,
I've got to add more decimal so we can even see it, uh,
chance of 100 fatalities or 1,000 fatalities.
[NOISE] Oops 1,000, there we go, it's still 0.1.
So- so this measure of risk does not distinguish between killing one person and killing
1,000 people [MUSIC] [NOISE] and it is in common use in regulation.
So there's a huge amount of low hanging fruit for people to go out and learn about
this stuff still in their organizations and change those organizations from within.
But great question and Agile development is a step in the right direction.
It's fantastic. And so in a big piece of it,
of course, is- is having this.
It tells you is being able to- to play with the model in front of someone to show,
demonstrate [OVERLAPPING] as the members change how
in real time that's changing the- the risk.
Risk intelligence now is being monitored and- and some people have it and some don't.
Gamblers have it because they didn't involve in limbic analytics.
They've let their butts on the line in
the casino and- and- and they're quite good at this.
That's excellent.
We're- we're pretty much out of time, uh,
I guess I- I want to remind everyone that,
uh, Professor Savage will be teaching this in more depth.
I posted the link to the course in the chat box if you're interested.
Uh, Professor Savage also has some, uh,
some edited videos on a lot of these topics on his website so you
can go there as well for tutorials and refresh yourself or to inform,
uh, your company about these important topics.
So I wanna thank Professor Savage again today.
I want to thank all of you for being here today and we really
a- appreciate your time and we hope you enjoyed it. Thank you.
Same to you.